ist das nun also ein macht ein
Gesichtsverlust für Christian Lindner
als Finanzminister ist er zuständig für
den Haushalt aber weil manche
Kabinettsmitglieder mit seinen
Sparvorgaben nicht einverstanden waren
schaltete sich der Kanzler ein lud die
Protestierenden Ministerinnen und
Minister zum Gespräch mit ihm und
Lindner das Olaf Scholz des eingreifen
musste zeigt wie Verfahren die Lage zur
Erstellung des hausesentwurf und
Kabinett ist es wurden mehrere Termine
gerissen der Termin für die Eckwerte der
Termin für den
kabinettsenwurf im Juni und dass der
Kanzler jetzt eingreifen müsste zu
Unterstützung ist schon bemerkenswerter
Vorgang wie so noch nicht gab sehr
Quatsch der Finanzminister braucht den
Kanzler nicht sondern der Kanzler macht
deutlich dass die ganze Regierung die
Verantwortung hat einen
verfassungskonform Haushalt vorzulegen
und das ist nicht der Job alleine das
Finanzminister die Verfassung
einzuhalten das finde ich sehr gut sehr
gut ablesen lässt sich am Streit um den
Haushalt wie es um die Ampel insgesamt
bestellt stellt ist atmosphärisch und
ums interne Kräfteverhältnis
auch Familienministerin Paulus muss
Vorsprechen wohl nur um sich erneut
anzuhören dass es nicht mehr Geld geben
wird für die Kindergrundsicherung ein
Kernanliegen der Grünen die drohen daher
mindestens indirekt nicht zuzustimmen
wenn der Haushalt hier in gut drei
Wochen beschlossen werden soll
geschwächt wird die Statik der Ampel zu
dem dadurch dass es nicht nur zwischen
den Parteien brodelt sondern nunmehr
denn je in ihnen selbst weil wir heute
ein historisches Ergebnis erreichen
konnten die
eu-migrationsbeschlüsse ausgehandelt von
der SPD Innenministerin zeigen nicht nur
bei den Grünen eine tiefe Spaltung
sondern auch in der SPD selbst die
juso-chefin nennt die Beschlüsse
beschämend
man will Menschen einsperren man will
Kinder einsperren und natürlich
enttäuscht ist uns sehr dass auch
Sozialdemokratinnen das dann mitgetragen
haben mir ist klar dass es in Europa
nicht einfach ist das zu verhandeln aber
dass wir diesen Kurs dann auch mitgehen
Menschen einzusperren das finde ich
wirklich sehr fatal zwischen den drei
ampelparteien bleibt der heftigste
Streit der um die Heizung um das Gebäude
Energiegesetz
das ist schon ein wirklich ein
Meilenstein in der
klimaschutzgesetzgebung in Deutschland
wenn es denn käme wenn es denn käme
selbst der Wirtschaftsminister klingt da
trotz seiner vielen Zugeständnisse
zuletzt nicht mehr sicher kaum helfen
wird dass die Grünen wie nun der Spiegel
berichtet ist seit mehr als drei Jahren
nicht schaffen in ihrer Parteizentrale
selbst eine Wärmepumpe einzubauen
technisch zu kompliziert Genehmigungen
braucht mehr Jahre sie selbst wiederum
klagen über etwas anderes was manche
inzwischen gar als Muster wahrnehmen
unterlassene Hilfeleistung aus dem
Kanzleramt das ist auch wichtig dass das
Kanzleramt darauf achtet dass Beschlüsse
eingehalten werden und nachher nicht der
Vertragsbruch belohnt werden da brauchen
wir stärkeres Vertrauen wieder in der
Ampel dass man so gemeinsam Beschlüssen
und den gemeinsamen Wort dass man
gegeben hat auch steht
Vertragsbruch Mangel an Vertrauen die
Ampel interne Kritik ist oft so
substanziell dass die Opposition selbst
diese Kritik kritisiert Deutschland hat
mehr verdient als eine Regierung die
sich so auf offener Bühne streitet und
zu keiner Lösung offensichtlich mehr
bereit und in der Lage ist genau dies
solche heftige
koalitionsinterner Streit droht indes
des neuen normal zu werden weil in einem
Parteienspektrum in dem es jenseits der
AFD FIFA schmaler wird Bündnisse mit
großer ideologischer Spannbreite
wahrscheinlicher werden erst recht wenn
sich einer der Partner als Korrektiv
versteht als mitunter sehr lautes wir
sind verschiedene Parteien wir haben
verschiedene Werte und auch verschiedene
Ziele für die wir uns einsetzen aber
wenn wir nach draußen gehen dann muss
klar sein dass diese Bundesregierung
funktioniert in der Theorie klingt das
einfach in der Praxis gelingt es seit
anderthalb Jahren kaum Haushalt
Migration das wie und wie weit beim
Klimaschutz die Gräben sind tief wie nie
die Legislatur nicht mal zur Hälfte
geschafft